je poursuis sur ce sujet avec gagner
chez nous elle est professeure adjointe
à l'école de politique appliquée de
l'université de sherbrooke bonsoir
madame chalus bonsoir
d'abord est-ce que ces résultats vous
surprennent non c'est pas des résultats
qui sont très surprenants la pandémie a
amené avec elle son lot d'insécurité
d'incertitude puis cette question là
donc et plastique à usage unique
permettait du moins dans un laps très
court laps de temps peut-être de combler
certaines inquiétudes que l'on peut
avoir est ce que vous croyez que ce
changement de pensée là pour rester ou
bien si la tendance pourrait s'inverser
lorsque par exemple la pandémie va
s'essouffler où sera derrière nous ça
c'est un mouvement qui date de très
longtemps donc les inquiétudes liées
notamment à tout lastic à usage unique
là on voit qu'il ya un intérêt qui
faibles y met néanmoins la crise demeure
donc si ce n'est que d'observer la
tendance on pourrait dire qu'ils qu'on
doit continuer à aller de l'avant bien
évidemment donc d'après vous la la
politique qui avait été proposé par le
gouvernement trudeau de bannir en tout
cas une sorte de certaines gammes de
produits classés que je table d'ici 2021
de 6 d'ici l'an prochain on devrait
poursuivre avec cette cet objectif là
d'après vous je pense que c'est
important qu'on poursuive
en fait cette politique là cette idée
donc d'interdire complètement plusieurs
plastique à usage unique parce que on a
déjà l'expertisé au pays
beaucoup d'entreprises qui travaillent
notamment dans tout les produits
compostables donc des produits de
remplacement qui pourrait donc comblé
toutes les plages l'utilisation du
plastique à usage unique d'une part même
si c'est un signal qu'on envoie en
termes de relance verte le gouvernement
actuellement est dans une situation où
on lui on lui a permis d'ouvrir les
valves et d'investir massivement dans
l'économie canadienne pour promouvoir
les entreprises locales et nationales
et là on est vraiment une opportunité de
faire fleurir cette industrie là qui est
une industrie du 21e siècle en scène mai
2021 l'horizon est il le bon on ne sait
pas encore de quoi sera fait l'automne
où la prochaine année quand même tout à
fait donc on voit que c'est un pari qui
est difficile
en même temps on est on sait aussi que
les changements comportements peuvent
survenir beaucoup plus rapidement que
prévu
si on n'avait pas les technologies si on
n'avait pas les industries qui était
derrière qui pouvait donc assumer ses
remplacements rire un peu taquiné
inquiétudes plus grandes mais on sait
qu'on a la capacité de faire les
changements et qui sont souhaités et ça
on parle simplement de remplacer par
exemple déplacer qu'à imaginer que par
des matières compostables
mais il ya aussi tout le vendent toutes
les usages des produits réutilisables
qui ont aussi qui avait l'avant n'a pas
émis le vent dans les voiles et faut
juste sécuriser les gens quant à la
sécurité de ce type de produit là mais
il ya plein d'entreprises qui avait
commencé par exemple a instauré des
systèmes de consignes et ça allait bien
et donc faux l'idée c'est vraiment de
sécuriser les gens d'abord mais je pense
qu'il faut continuer à accélérer le
mouvement pour une transition sur
l'utilisation du plastique parce que
dans ce cas ci on a vu que les gens
justement parlé de sécuriser la
population on a eu beaucoup de craintes
entre autres au départ on ne savait pas
trop si le virus restait par exemple
vivant sur des surfaces les sacs
réutilisables dans les épiceries était
interdite on a aussi plus que doublé les
ventes en ligne donc les gens soient
livrés les choses à la maison fallait
les emballer ces produits là oui tout à
fait c'est ce qui est un peu qu'ils
étaient difficiles dans la situation où
de manière urgente on a dû donc faire un
180 sur beaucoup de nos pratiques de
consommation
ceci étant dit existe tellement
d'alternative maintenant par exemple
tout ce qui est styromousse peut être
remplacée par exemple des produits avec
des films même de patates
il ya plein de produits compostables qui
peuvent être utilisés qui peuvent être
développés qui existait déjà
donc si les gouvernements investissent
dans ces industriels pour leur donner ce
second souffle et là ils vont peut-être
être près des gens à faire face à cette
deuxième pas glop et d'amorcer une
transition ceci étant dit aussi le volet
de responsabilité élargie des
producteurs
on va dire que les entreprises pendant
très très longtemps sont un peu demeuré
sourde à l'impact que l'an
à l'âge de leurs produits ou leurs
produits eux mêmes avaient et cette
mouvance même on doit responsabiliser
les producteurs sur l'impact que ça
et plus on tarde avant de mettre en
place des mesures draconiennes mais plus
les gens vont rester un peu confortable
dans leurs chaussures ils ne voudront
pas changé leur manière de faire mais je
pense que la crise climatique est une
crise suffisamment importante est
suffisamment urgente pour que on doit
donc faire un pas de plus et continuer
dans cette échéance il en même temps
madame jaloux on sait qu'il ya eu des
difficultés financières pour les
canadiens pour les entreprises aussi des
arrêts de production même et puis
j'imagine que ça coûte plus cher quand
même si solutions écologiques le nom
rapidement
tout à fait c'est il ya un aspect qui
est plus dispendieux à la base ceci
étant dit c'est là où les gouvernements
peuvent investir on peut continuer de
faire le choix par exemple des
gouvernements de faire certains types de
subventions à certains types
d'industries plus polluantes les
industries des carburants fossiles par
exemple qui est un aspect qui est très
critiqué mais au moment où les
gouvernements ouvrent les vannes b offre
des opportunités aux entreprises de
changer si on veut leur leur manière de
faire mais ils peuvent subventionner ces
nouvelles façons de faire là qui
justement limiterait le coût pour les
entreprises et pour les consommateurs et
donc faire ses choix écologiques à
l'échelle ou merci beaucoup merci à vous
pour voir